ces deux jeunes filles vont recevoir une
dose de vaccin particularité du centre
il est mobile ce lundi 20 décembre levac
cybus fait un arrêt à montfort l'amaury
on avait vu des rendez-vous c'était sur
paris donc c'était un peu compliqué pour
nous donc ici c'était parfait les
yvelines ont remis en circulation leurs
vaccins bus depuis le 2 décembre
trois véhicules sillonnent le
département pour administrer les vaccins
contre la coved 19 on vient vers la
population et notamment les populations
qui sont les moins mobiles donc en
priorité les personnes âgées qui ne
peuvent pas aller jusqu'à un centre de
vaccination par exemple avec la
saturation des centres de vaccination
qui ont été observés ces dernières
semaines on a ouvert la vaccination au
moins de 30 ans en diversifiant notre
proposition on a on a un petit peu de
pfizer en plus du moderna pour pouvoir
répondre aux besoins des populations
lancé au printemps dernier cette
nouvelle campagne a débuté dans des
villes identifiés par la rs le
département s'est ensuite rapproché des
communes non rattachés à des centres de
vaccination 35 bénéficient de ce service
cela fait un certain temps quand même
que nous avons été sollicités pour la
troisième injection de la part de nos
montfortois et aux alentours
devant une telle difficulté pour obtenir
des rendez vous notamment au centre des
mesnuls
nous avons contacté le département avec
qui nous en plus mettre en place cette
expérience de maximus que nous avions
déjà vécu l'an passé huit personnes du
conseil départemental se déplace avec
l'ensemble du matériel jusqu'à 200
patients peuvent être vaccinés par jour
les vaccins bus seront à elancourt le 22
décembre à plaisir le 23